hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
driving lab efficiency with pcr power
i am sabrina lemoos of lab routes and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
please note we will be distributing poll
questions throughout the webinar
your participation is greatly
appreciated
i now present today's speaker kyle
hondorp
the senior product manager thermal
cyclers and plastics
thermo fisher scientific and maria navas
gupta
the product manager dna polymerase
thermo fisher scientific for a complete
biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
maria and kyle you may now begin your
presentations
thank you sabrina for for the
introduction
and welcome everyone to today's webinar
driving lab efficiency with pcr power
there are three objectives that we aim
to achieve with
this webinar one is help you to discover
ways to get the most from your pcr
and improve lab efficiency two
understand
key aspects of critical pcr components
and instrumentation
and three learn how to avoid common
pcare mistakes and
troubleshoot pcr issues when they arise
here is the outline of today's webinar i
will start with a brief background about
pcr
then i will talk about ways to enhance
your pci productivity
how to design ideal primasco pcr and my
colleague kyle
will continue talking about
instrumentation and
plastics for pcr
so let's begin with a brief background
polymerase chain reaction or pcr is a
molecular biology method used to amplify
or multiply dna pcr works even from a
single dna molecule
each amplification cycle consisting of
template denaturation
primary annealing and primer extension
steps
during each cycle each dna copy is
increased
two-fold so for example after the second
amplification round
you will have four copies of the same
dna after the 30th cycle
10 to the power of 9 copies of the same
starting dna
so this is a really powerful technique
to study
dna and its analysis
pcr needs several components to work
there is of course a dna polymerase that
synthesizes a new strand
from a primer by incorporating
nucleotides
all these components are mixed in a
special plastic plate so
or tubes which are then loaded to the
thermal cycler to begin
cycling protocol and we will review most
of these components
in more detail in today's webinar
let's begin from from dna polymerases
adenine polymerase synthesizes a new dna
strand
and there are several
several activities that are important
for pcr
synthesis of the new strand relies on
five prime to three prime polymerase
activity
and all polymerases process this
activity
another is three prime to five prime
exonuclease activity
which removes misincorporated
nucleotides
dna polymerases with this activity are
commonly known as
proofreading enzymes because it helps to
ensure
sequence accuracy during amplification
and these enzymes are commonly used in
applications that require
a high fidelity pcr
polymerases possess other activities as
well that are important
for pcr processivity
is a measure of of a number of
nucleotides incorporated by the enzyme
in a single binding event until the
enzyme dissociates
from the template this activity is also
related to the enzyme's affinity
or how tightly it binds to the template
high perceptivity of enzyme contributes
to faster dna synthesis
higher inhibitor tolerance and ability
to amplify
longer dna fragments
another property hostart
helps ensure higher specificity and
sensitivity
dna polymerases can be active at room
temperature
while polymerases with hot start
mechanisms
are not these enzymes are activated
during
denaturation step at high temperatures
ensuring that amplification begins only
in a thermocycler giving you
a specific amplification only
now let's take a look at how hot start
enzymes can help increase your lab
productivity
amplification of non-specific dna
fragments
is a common pcr issue it can be caused
by
room temperature reaction setup because
any polymerases are somewhat
active at room temperature this is a
problem as primers might bind to
non-specific targets and give rise to
unwanted unwanted pcr products
similar to what you see in lanes 2 and 3
of in the gel image on the right
this can be avoided if the reaction is
set up on ice but
still enzymes activity is not fully
inhibited
an easiest solution to avoid this is to
use a hot start enzyme which is modified
to be inactive at room temperature
the hotspot modifier it can be
antibody chemical antibody or aptomer
in any case the reaction has to be
heated first
to activate the enzyme remove the
modifier
and enable synthesis of the new dna
strand
way a hot start enzyme provides better
specificity and yield
in pcro which can be seen in the
fourth and fifth lanes in the gel image
on the right
if you are using a proofreading enzyme
blocking
three prime to five prime exonuclease
activity is
especially critical non-hot start
proofreading enzymes or
proof eating enzymes with suboptimal hot
start mechanism
can have lower sensitivity and
specificity
especially when working with high
complexity dna
like human genomic theory and this is
because the exonuclease
or the proofreading activity can degrade
primers or templates
even before the pcr starts and
as you can see an example in the image
on the right
to prevent this you can use a
proofreading enzyme with
stringent hot start mechanism that
blocks both
polymerase and proofreading activities
and this enables detection of low
concentration targets
and amplify specific bands
now if you set up pcr using liquid
handling or robotic platforms
stability of assembled reactions at room
temperature is critical to achieve
optimal results hot start modifications
of pcr enzymes makes this
benchtop stability possible and if you
use a stringent hot start
you can achieve stability for
up to 24 hours
as you can see in the gel image on the
right
the same result was obtained when pcr
was
ran after this setup and when it was
left
for 24 hours at room temperature
if you are looking for a hot start
enzyme our in vitrogen
platinum pcr enzymes are designed with
antibody based platinum hotstar
technology
these antibodies fully inhibit enzyme
activity until the
initial denaturation step which means
greater target yield sensitivity
benchtop stability
and ability to set up reactions at room
temperature
and now let's move on and talk about
high fidelity pcr enzymes
polymerases can be defined by the error
rate that they make
the error rate of an enzyme is defined
as
the number of incorrect nucleotides per
total nucleotides
incorporated it can range from one in
millions
for high fidelity enzymes to one in
thousands for low fidelity
if you compare error rates or or
fidelity information for different dna
polymerases
it is important to keep in mind that
there are different ways to measure
fidelity
and the results can vary significantly
there are three commonly used methods to
measure fidelity
that are shown here on the slide so on
the left there is a
colony screening assay
anger sequencing in the middle and on
the right next generation sequencing
so when comparing fidelity of different
polymerases
it is important to note the method that
was used
and only compare values that were
measured using the same methodology
and best if measured under the same
conditions
now colonies creating assays and sanger
sequencing both require
a huge amount of data to estimate
statistically significant
and reliable error rates of high
fidelity polymerases
nowadays next generation sequencing
enables analysis of large amounts of
data
and simplifies quantification of
statistical data
in this example in the graph fidelity of
dna polymerases was measured by
next generation sequencing
the values were normalized to tags any
polymerase
so here the value indicates how many
times
fidelity of the proofreading dna
polymerase is
higher compared to tac
measurements for these polymerases
indicated in the graph
were made side by side under the same
conditions
allowing accurate comparison of the
results
and let's look at how high-fidelity
enzymes can improve your lab
productivity
if you do cloning or sequencing any
sequence accuracy is critical
you want to minimize possibility of
having an
error in the pcr sequence and this is
where it is critical
to use a high fidelity polymerase
if you are to choose a pcr enzyme with
the highest fidelity possible
that will increase your confidence in
the dna sequence accuracy after
amplification
and save and save your time from
troubleshooting
and repetition of the experiment
we will now look into pcr enzymes with
high processivity and
how it can simplify pcr when working
with challenging samples
as was mentioned before processivity is
defined as the number of
nucleotides incorporated by the enzyme
in a single binding event to the dna
template
the higher the processivity the more
nucleotides the enzyme can incorporate
without
falling off the strand this often leads
to faster synthesis rate
and increased enzyme affinity to the
substrate
so how can a higher processivity of an
enzyme help
in a daily pcr
if you amplify dna from inhibitor rich
samples
like plants blood or soil
you may have difficulty with your pcr
this is typical because
pcr inhibitors are not completely
removed during
dna purification in such case
if you use highly processive enzyme you
can come
you you can overcome pcr inhibition
because these polymerases tolerate
sub-optimal reaction conditions
you can see an example here shown on the
right
where dna samples were amplified with
spiked
known pcr inhibitors using highly
processive platinum to attack dna
polymerase
it is often a challenge to amplify long
dna fragments
for example longer than 10 kilobase
success rates often low there is high
error rate and long
cycling protocol in such situations
high fidelity enzyme with high
processivity can simplify the workflow
because the enzyme ensures low error
rate and better amplification of longer
fragments
while high processivity of the enzyme
leads to
shorter cycling time and also increases
success rate
of the amplification overall
uh the gel image on the right side
shows amplification of 20 kilobases from
human genomic dna and
even up to 40 kilobases from e-coli
genomic dna
using our high-fidelity platinum
super phyto dna polymerase
gc rich dna amplification is another
common challenge in pcr
gc rich regions are harder to separate
and we can form secondary structures
after the separation most often
additives like dmso
are used to overcome these challenges
also there are specialized enhancers
available with some enzymes
that simplify reaction optimization
now our latest platinum superfine 2
enzyme
comes with an innovative buffer that
allows amplification of gc rich targets
without a need for an enhancer bringing
down
all the optimization efforts to a
minimum
and in the next section i will talk
about some
some other ways uh how to increase
efficiency
when doing pcr
and one way is to choose direct pcr
approach
which enables pcr without prior dna
purification
cutting down the workflow time
significantly
the conventional pcr involves dna
purification
which can take from an hour to several
hours
depending on the method direct pcr does
not require this
and you can get from sample to pcr in
less than an hour in addition
their fpcr is handy when working with
very small samples as it requires
minimal handling and minimizes chances
to lose
the sample completely
it is also an ideal choice when working
with many samples in in high throughput
labs
for example for genotyping experiments
now the needing temperature for primers
often needs optimization to help ensure
efficient binding of the primers
to achieve the best result
it is a long and tedious process
especially if you work with
multiple primer sets however
our latest platinum pcr enzymes
are formulated with universal primer
annealing
temperature these enzymes allow you to
use
60 degrees annealing temperature for
different primer sets you can see
an example on the right where
all all dna fragments were amplified
at 60 degrees while their actual
calculated melting temperatures are
ranges from
59 to 69 degrees
this universal annealing feature
provides
two additional benefits shown here
first you can amplify multiple different
length fragments
in the same run or using the same
60 degrees annealing temperature and
using extension time
of the longest fragment
as depicted in the image on the top
fragments up to five kilobases can be
amplified without
losing specificity or yield
what this also means is that
different pcr assays can be cycled
together
using one cent thermocycler as shown in
the bottom image
typically with other enzymes different
pcr assays need to be run sequentially
or on different instruments so really
universal
primary annealing significantly saves
time
when it comes to reaction preparation
and also a cycling step
and lastly i will just briefly summarize
how to choose a right enzyme
based on your application
if you need to detect a target sequence
you basically get a yes or no answer
or use a low fidelity enzyme
for example platinum two tags in a
polymerase
now if you need to preserve dna sequence
accuracy
in applications like cloning with
sequencing or mutagenesis
high fidelity enzymes like platinum
superfight 2
will benefit you if you want
to detect target dna from samples
without purifying
dna choose platinum direct pci universal
master mix
because that will save you a lot of your
time
and down at the bottom there is a link
where you can find more information
about our
platinum enzyme family
and now primers primers are essential
for pcr
so let's look at some tips how to
simplify your pcr by
designing good primers
if primers were not designed correctly
you will either get
no amplification or lots of non-specific
products it is essential to follow
primer design rules to design primer for
optimal results here on the right
you can see several tips to keep in mind
when designing primers
that is a primer length gc content
number of dinucleotides or repetitive
bases
these are just some of the aspects to
consider when
designing a new primer pair or
you can use the specialized tools for
private design
where you do not really need to think
about these rules
and one example would be
a oligoperfect primer designer
online tool
and now my colleague kyle will continue
talking about thermocyclers and
plastics thank you very much maria for
all that wonderful information
beyond the selection of appropriate
reagents and primers to improve
pcr efficiency instrumentation
also plays a critical role in driving
pcr
success
it is important to select a thermal
cycler
that ensures precise temperature control
thermal cyclers that deliver
inconsistent temperatures
can impact the accuracy of pcr results
especially if seeking a specific
annealing temperature
or performing pcr optimization protocols
this can lead to confusing results and
require
additional time to re-optimize protocols
to overcome this
one way to achieve the solution is to
look for a thermal cycler that provides
precise temperature control
a traditional gradient temperature
control
allows you to set a minimum temperature
on one side of the block
and a maximum temperature on the other
side
heat then transfers across the block in
a gradient but it lacks temperature
accuracy at any specific
well there are technologies available
that allow for precise temperature
control
the veriflex block technology
temperature control technology
utilizes blocks constructed of metal
segments each segment contains its own
heating and cooling elements depending
on the instrument
you can find either three or six
independent temperature zones
with the ability to uniquely control
each zone
you're able to achieve accurate
temperature control
which is ideal for enzyme studies
restriction digest
or any workflow requiring temperature
precision
if your lab is limited with the number
of thermal cyclers available
this can create backlogs and scheduling
and delays
and time to results today there are
thermal cyclers with very basic
features and small footprints
available at a reasonable price
this makes it easy to obtain
personalized instrumentation
allowing more lab members to have access
to their own benchtop thermal cyclers
one of the challenges many researchers
face when switching to a new model of
thermal cycler
is the ability to transition protocols
to the new instrument
without needing to re-optimize
experiments
thermal cyclers can operate using
different ramp rates
this makes it challenging to replicate
experimental results
across instruments to solve for this
look for thermal cyclers that offer
simulation mode
simulation mode provides a library of
instrument modes
that mimic the ramp rate of those
instruments
this makes it easy to transition
protocols and workflows
without the need to re-optimize
simulation mode is available on applied
biosystems thermal cyclers
another way to improve pcr efficiency
is having the ability to manage pcr
protocols and runs
while away from the lab look for
instruments that offer secure remote
access
with a wi-fi or cloud-enabled instrument
securely connect through your mobile
device or desktop computer
to start or stop a run design and share
protocols
or export data
this gives you greater control over your
research
whether you are in the lab or working
remotely
one area to improve pcr efficiency
that is often overlooked is the
selection of
optimal pcr plastics to fit your
instruments
thermal cycler manufacturers design
thermal blocks
and instrument lids to fit either a
limited
or wide range of pcr plastics
plastics that don't fit the thermal
block can lead to deformation
or crushing causing sample of aspiration
or loss of results
to solve this use the manufacturer
recommended plastics designed to fit
your pcr
or qpcr instrument
you can find recommended plastics by
using manufacturer compatibility tables
or use free online pcr plastic selection
guides
to confirm the fit of the plastic with
your specific instrument model
at the bottom of the slide you will find
a link to an online plastic selection
guide
for plastic compatibility with applied
biosystems
and other instrument manufacturers
pcr tubes are available in a variety of
sizes and formats
how do you select the right fit
first you need to know the profile of
your thermal block
are you working with a standard 0.2 mil
block
or a 0.1 mil also known as a fast
thermal block the tubes are different
sizes
to fit the appropriate block style
so make sure you select and know the
block format that you're working with
for the best fit
the second consideration is what style
cap do you need
domed caps are used in endpoint pcr
and can help absorb lid pressure and
prevent tube crushing
in instruments with inner concave lids
flat caps are recommended for
instruments that have a flat lid
and ultra clear cap are used when
working with real-time pcr
instruments
for experiments that require additional
throughput
we recommend the use of tube strips
dupe strips are available with either
eight tubes or twelve tubes
you can find tube strips that come with
tubes and caps separately
or to prevent cross-contamination we
recommend using
tube strips with attached cap
this will allow you to independently
open and close
each tube as you're working with that
particular sample
again use compatibility tables
or online selection guides to make sure
that the plastic is the right
fit for your thermal cycler
pcr plate selection also depends on the
instrument
lights come in a variety of styles they
can be non-skirted
semi-skirted or also known as
half-skirted
or skirted automation usually requires a
semi
or full skirted plate while non-skirted
plates
offer more flexibility to fit many
thermal block formats
the applied biosystems thermal cyclers
use
semi-skirted plates
deck style is another consideration
a flat deck offers the most universal
fit
with instrument lids and is also
compatible with
automated heat sealers while
raised decks are plates that have a
plastic lip that goes all the way around
the outer edge of the plate
this is required to help balance lid
pressure on certain thermal cyclers
and is required to fit with certain
certain thermal cycler lids
finally when should you seal with caps
versus films calf strips can be used for
both
tubes and plates they must fit securely
and seal tightly in order to avoid
evaporation
film is often used when working with 96
or 384 well plates
and film has the advantage that it can
be cut into smaller sizes
to fit segmented plates containing 24
32 or 48 wells
adhesive clear film or adhesive oil
can be used in endpoint pcr
while optically clear film is
recommended for real-time instruments
optically clear film is a pressure
sensitive film
and requires pressure to be applied to
form a proper seal
for more information about forming a
proper seal we do recommend the use of
an adhesive film
applicator when using the applicator you
apply
pressure gently and evenly across
the rims of every well to ensure that
the adhesive
deals with the well to prevent any
sample loss
other sealing considerations may include
considering the deck of the plate
especially if you're wanting to use an
automated ceiling method system
or the type of lettering do you need
raised or engraved lettering
to ensure you get a proper seal
for more information about any of the
pcr workflow topics
we have discussed we have assembled some
resources
we have a pcr workflow solution brochure
that goes through various portions of
the pcr workflow
you can also find more information on
our product pages
for our pcr enzymes thermal cyclers
or pcr plastics you can click the link
to get access to our pcr application
notes
we also have a pcr education webpage
that will discuss considerations for pcr
as well as common troubleshooting tips
links to our various brochures and
handbooks
will help further your understanding of
the pcr workflow
and the products available to support
your research
our hope is that this webinar provided
you with helpful insight
to drive your lab efficiency with
powerful pcr tools
designed for speed simplicity and
accuracy
i thank you for your time today and now
marie and i
will be happy to take any questions
thank you maria and kyle for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question
do i still need to use the universal
annealing temperature
i trust annealing temperatures i
calculated
oh thank you for the first question um
the answer is uh no uh you don't have to
use universal
primary annealing temperature the
enzymes
will work with the calculated
temperatures as well
but the universal kneeling feature is
convenient when
you are working with multiple primer
sets
wonderful the next question i have how
do i get samples of the enzymes you
mentioned
i thank you for the question uh yes so
to get the samples please contact
our thermo fisher sales representatives
and in some countries you can also
request the
product samples directly on our website
wonderful the next question i have what
type of pcr plastics do you recommend
if i am automating some of my workflow
with a robot
that's a great question there are
actually two factors to consider when
thinking about using plastics for
robotics
the first one will be the skirt type as
i mentioned before
semi-skirted and fully skirted plastics
are usually recommended for automation
that's important because the robotic
grippers or paddles
that move the plates around will need
some surface in order to do their
gripping
the second consideration is the pcr
plastic material
some plates are prone to warping and
cannot work well within automation
automated processes therefore we would
recommend
plates that are constructed with a
stronger polycarbonate frame
which resists distortion caused by those
robotic grippers
and tolerates the robotic transfer well
those plates still contain the same thin
walled polypropylene wells that are
traditional in all pcr
plastics but that frame makes an
important difference
and for thermo fisher scientific we have
both
the endura plate and the armadillo
options for polycarbonate frame plastics
thank you so much the next one i have
do your thermal cyclers have
gradient capability
great question the proflex
verity pro and simply amp thermal
cyclers
feature our veriflex block technology so
this is that precise
temperature control the instrument
either contains three or six segmented
metal blocks
each with their own heating and cooling
element so that each zone
can be set with a unique and independent
temperature
our verity pro instrument also has the
ability
to set temperature based on the minimum
and maximum temperature across
the block or to set the midpoint which
is our zone three range of the thermal
block
thank you so much the next one i have
fidelity value that you showed in the
graph
does look different from what i see on
my enzymes manual can you explain that
that's a great question thank you
yes correct fidelity values
can different it can differ
depending on the methods used in
measuring and so
different companies
will show different values for their
products
as it was mentioned during the webinar
um for example
if values were measured using the lack
based method it will vary significantly
compared to
values measured using next generation
sequencing
and this is especially true for
for higher fidelity enzymes where you
really need
to use a sensitive mesh method to
measure fidelity
accurately uh the bottom line though is
when comparing fidelity values of
different enzymes
they should be measured side by side
using the same method
under the same conditions
wonderful thank you we have time for a
few more here
do you have direct kit for rna
yes we do have a direct kit for rna
we recently launched a new kit it is
called
superscript for cells direct
it synthesizes the cdna directly from
rna of cell samples
thank you another question tell me more
about wireless connectivity
yes cloud enabled instruments allow you
the freedom to design
and securely upload your methods monitor
runs or check instrument availability
from
any mobile device or desktop computer
you simply need to look for an
instrument that's wi-fi or cloud enabled
and connect to it
great and how can i prevent sample
evaporation during pcr
great question proper sealing of your
pcr reactions
is essential to preventing evaporation
and sample loss
if you're using an adhesive film you
want to make sure that it properly fits
the size of the plate
and to align the cover across all wells
adhesive film will stick an optical film
does require
it's pressure sensitive and requires
pressure but in both cases we do
recommend the use of the adhesive
applicator tool
to firmly press across the entire film
and to make sure that the rims of
every well are securely connected and
sealed
you can also use cap strips with plates
so if you're not getting a proper seal
that's another option is to consider
using cap strips
as long as you ensure that the cap strip
has a tight fit
in with the plate so those are a few
suggestions on how to properly seal
thank you okay let's see here the next
one i have
can the choice of hot start modifier
make a difference
well that's a great question thank you
now my short answer would be
yes there is a difference and it mainly
depends
on your application so for example
antibody modifiers are quite stringent
and can fully inactivate the enzymes
but antibodies are proteins so they not
mean so they may not be suitable if your
application
requires low protein concentrations
uh chemical modification
modifies the enzyme so the enzyme
that is that has a chemical hot stars
may not be
fully reactivated during the activation
step
which quite often impacts the
amplification
of log sequences and sometimes enzyme
sensitivity and
then antibody and aptamer
so these are small molecules uh
they're not proteins but they may not be
as
stringent uh depending on their
dissociation temperatures
thank you so much and the next one i
have
direct pcr sounds great but what are its
drawbacks
oh it's a good question um
so one thing to keep in mind with direct
pcr is that
you are not actually purifying dna which
is
which is good if you don't need it but
if you need a purified genomic dna for a
certain downstream application
then a direct pcn may not be
a good approach for you to use
uh the next thing is that a sample size
is important uh because if you add
too too little uh you may not get
any amplification the signal will be too
low
or if you add too much of your sample
it will inhibit the pcr reaction
we do have some guidelines
on our website uh how much
of samples to add depending on on the
sample type
and depending on on the protocols are
used for
direct pcr
wonderful i have two more questions here
um premier design
rules look complicated i've seen some
tools on the web
any that you would recommend
uh yes of course uh we recommend
using our three uh online tool called
oligoperfect designer the design rules
are built into the algorithm um
so you don't really need to think about
all those
rules and we also
recently updated its bulk ordering
function to simplify the ordering if you
have
many primer pairs
perfect and i have one more question
that we're going to wrap up with
do i need to measure fidelity of the
enzyme that i am using
uh no you don't have to measure a
fidelity of the enzyme that you
are using it is a really tedious process
and uh usually the enzyme suppliers
do that for you
wonderful thank you again marie and kyle
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time thank you again maria
and kyle goodbye